[Applause]
Sammy has the good afternoon everyone
nice to be here again thank you thank
you very much and this is the book I
will read it Oliver the ornament meets
Belle do you know the book did you read
it before no Christmas season started
with mom and dad telling Henry and Holly
about the ornaments on their tree and
that was just the beginning of the
holiday fun for the entire Nelson
household a lot of stories Krister
acclaimed me to Etzel said but there is
a lot of more to the story of how Belle
entered their collection
please tell us Henry asked Oliver
reminded them that at first he was the
only ornament on the tree that didn't
last long because the next day your mom
came home with a box of beautiful
ornaments Oliver said suddenly I was
surrounded by so many magical friends or
so I thought what do you mean Holly
asked well I want up to the ornaments
and introduced myself
Oliver explained but sadly none of them
answered that didn't last long continued
Oliver because I began playing the most
wonderful game of make-believe
I went back to each of the ornaments and
introduced myself again I said hello mr.
red ornament my name is Oliver mr. red
ornament replied hello Oliver my
name is odd so I said
hello miss blue ornament she responded
nice to meet you
I'm crystal then I got to mrs. green
ornament but before I could say hello
she said hi Oliver I'm Mary
the children were amazed
Oliver's imagination brought all the
Ormond ornaments to life what happened
next
they asked we started by singing our
favorite Christmas carols Oliver said
just then the ornaments heard a very
scary laugh coming from the Attic not
wanting the children to hear the noise
the ornaments began singing Christmas
carols drowning out the scary laughter
then the doorbell ranked it was Henry
and Holly's friends
Stephen and Rudy so mom and dad bundled
the children up to go outside to build a
snowman back in the living room the
ornaments were scared where did that
laugh come from Belle asked it's from a
really mean ornament Oliver said her
name is Nelly who is nearly happy asked
she's mean and she's done some really
naughty stuff Oliver said she glue my
ladder down so it stuck I had so said
she bullied me and called me useless
bucked added Joan and Marley said I've
got to talk to Nelly it's Christmas
after all
that sounds like a bad idea Nora
and Teddy shouted but Marley and Joan
were determined so they flew off to meet
her on the way Marlene Joan could see it
was a cold and snowy and starting to get
dark
they were almost at the Attic Winn
when they heard a voice call out come in
here and play with me all the window at
the window Marley and John tried to open
it but it was too heavy try harder
nearly snickered I want to play Marley
and Joan try harder and got the window
open but as they did nearly pulled a
court crashing it down trapping them
both the angels looked at each other
then look back to see nearly laughing at
both of them I guess we are in a pickle
now Marley said Marley and John tried to
open the window but they couldn't they
were getting cold and scared inside
nearly laughs Adam Marley sound your
Horan
John said but Marley didn't want to it
was it would make too much noise Marley
Joanie's he stood sound the horn so
Marley sounded the horn to let other
ornaments know they were in trouble
Oliver and Etzel hopped off the tree and
went outside and so that Marley and John
were stuck cold and shivering Oliver I'm
not going to be able to help nearly
glued my leather down I'm useless Etzel
said Etzel you're strong enough to break
the glue and courage Oliver what Dad
courage meant Advil broke the glue and
extended the ladder
Oliver ran up the ladder and pushed the
window as hard as he could
it finally opened freeing Marley and
Joan the Angels flew back in the house
as they did Joan looked back and said
keep up the good work all the ornaments
cheered Oliver and Etzel Marley and Joan
were revealed but still shivering we
have got to get through Nellie
said I think she said Marley agree and
they convinced all the others to find a
way to cheer her up back in the Attic
nearly didn't understand why Marley and
Joan had tried to be kind to her it must
be a trick
she thought the children came back
inside and raised to the tree building
the Snowman was fun Holly said next time
we will bring you with us we are fine we
are where we are
Marley and Joan said we will just stay
put
tell us the rest of the story how you
met Belle Henry said it was fun at first
playing and singing with all my friends
Oliver said I never knew make-believe
could be so magical but after a while it
started getting harder and harder what
happened
hanji asked one one by one friends stop
talking and playing with me I spoke to
them but non answered I felt all alone
and it was Christmas Eve
Oliver choked up so Bell finished the
story everyone was singing carols and
having fun but sadly Oliver felt all
alone that so said Oliver Holly said
well thanks to Santa it turned out
perfect
Oliver's answer what happened with Santa
Henry
in the stockings Santa saw me and could
tell me I was sad after I told him what
I was wrong he said Oliver as long as
you believe in the magic of kindness and
of Christmas you will never be alone
just keep believing I promise
Santa I would on Christmas morning your
dad came over to exchange your gifts
with your mom
he gave her a sweater and the guy gave
him a watch then he gave her a small box
what was that whole Holly asked a
beautiful Bell ornament your dad brought
it for your mom because she leave horn
Bell Street Oliver said both Henry and
Holly laughed
that's what daddy told us earlier Holly
said after your mom and dad left I
remember Santa's words said Oliver so I
decided to speak to the new ornament
hello my name is Oliver
I said Belle's eyes open and she replied
it's very nice to meet you Oliver
my name is Belle I couldn't believe it
yeah I finally had a really friend that
was our first Christmas Belle said and
that made it special but each Christmas
becomes more special because we have
even more wonderful memories later that
night when the family fell asleep the
magic of Christmas lead the tree and all
the ornaments sang together their hearts
were filled with joy
remembering the story of Oliver's first
Christmas with Belle and thinking about
their plans to become friends with
Nellie with those happy thoughts
everyone in Nelson household went to
sleep
Merry Christmas and happy and healthy
New Year
[Applause]
thank you so much for that beautiful
reading of my story Oliver the ornament
meets Belle mrs. Trump and thank you for
everything that you do to promote
kindness and fight bullying here and
around the world
today we're gonna sign a book we're
gonna both sign a book if you would and
we're gonna donate this book to the
children Resource Center here at
Children's National Hospital
we know you have so many in but
invitation so many things you could be
doing it's just so meaningful that you
would come be with us today and read the
story for all the children and see all
the kids in the hospital so thank you so
much I know how much they appreciate
your generosity your warmth and the
feeling it's just so inspiring so all of
us here at Children's wanted to express
our gratitude back to you with some
gifts and these are an expression of our
gratitude from the children and the
families
thank you very much that's very special
some presents for Christmas so for more
than 70 years children's national has
had the great privilege of hosting the
first ladies of the United States and
it's always one of the most special days
of the year and if you think about it 70
years tradition and children's national
itself is a hundred and fifty years old
next year we're gonna have a big
birthday party so look forward to that
thank you mrs. Trump for continuing the
tradition now all of you please remain
seated until mrs. Trump has the has the
opportunity to depart the room please
stay in your seats thank you thank you
for having me amazing doctors nurses
Merry Christmas again
thank you Chris
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Tydings good tidings for Christmas and a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the halls with thousand tis the season
to be jolly
[Music]
[Music]
the
welcome our specialist
we thought we're opening our advent
calendar for today yeah I might do some
reading open that one for us buddy
brave boys but I could say
so
some snowflakes
yeah
all right so first we have to fold them
in half
I'm gonna commit little cuts yes you can
cut anywhere you want
if you like
sheesh
maybe could do over the weekend so it's
not too late you know summer comes
very good